this question five starts off like this
it tells you if these guys ah the cube
roots of unity so we were talking about
this just a second ago and then we asked
to improve a whole bunch of algebraic
results okay so he comes the first one
hi hey what they want us to prove is so
we're firmly algebra land right we're
just trying to think about these and is
there an algebraic relationship between
each of them how do we go about and
prove that this is the case okay what I
need to figure out first is well what
are these things
what are 1 and W 1 and W 2 well you
already sort of alluded to we're not
gonna join just yet but we alluded to
the fact that I know where these are
positioned right I know where their
positions so I can say well this is the
first room W 1 and W 2 because they
should be equally spaced around the
circumference of the unit circle okay if
what I can actually know what they are
thinking of a up W 1 that's the first
one going around we said how far do you
have to go to play on three because it's
two pounds three because they've got
cube roots right so to Python 3 is the
ugly event plus I sine 2 pi 3 happy with
now when you have a look at W to the
last of the roots you can state it in
two different ways you can say it in two
different ways I could say keep going
another 2 pi and 3 that that would be
fine what would that be the argument is
if you went it before part three right
you go this far and then you go another
foot one two and three so you add them
okay in fact I might write that down now
this is one way of stating it but I hope
you recall when I introduced polar form
that we generally try and get the
smallest argument we can
okay we call that the principle argument
so there's actually a quicker way to
rotate around the circle to get to this
point I don't have to go for apply on
three all the way this way it would be
faster to go maybe two hundred three
perfect okay so it's the same it's the
same number right I've just gone there
by a different puzzle okay so let's have
a look can we use these to say these
okay well let's have a look at consider
the conjugate of W to the conjugate of W
- hmm what does it mean for something to
be a country this is no me - yeah well
the conjugate of W - he's going to be
you know you can think about it either
of these ways there's X plus iy if this
is X plus iy what does X minus iy
look like well there's the X there's the
real plot do you agree and then he comes
the - to take it to the conjugate which
is the other direction right okay now
what am I supposed to prove that this is
equal to again when you're doing improve
boys don't know where you're going what
do I want this to be equal to I want to
equal to this right I want to be equal
to this now hopefully you can see that
these are going to be equal but it's
important to you that you know why
you've got to provide a reason is it's a
show question right so for example on
what grounds could I have reason to
justify that this is equal to this
actually mention it before what else
talking about cosine cosine is an even
function right so I'm going to say cos 2
pi and 3 under face this with this I'll
leave this for a second I'll come back
to this and work with it
the reason the reason I can just do that
is because since cause Vito is an even
function right I have to state that I
have to explain why it's a proof
question right it's not like I can just
read the question and say I'm supposed
to get a close to 5 to 3 and so I guess
it may be equal don't know why you'd
have to know why that's the point okay
look at this guy this is supposed to
land here what's the reason
what's the reason there I can do that I
can make that transition okay I can
cancel out the minuses but you have to
be careful with that is there a reason I
can cancel out the minuses and you have
to know why for example I've seen
students from 7 to 12 say to me well
that's 0 because you cancel out the
minuses okay you know clearly that's an
incorrect application of cancelling out
the minuses smart routing but why is
canceling out the minuses okay
here because you're telling me what I'm
doing but you're not telling me why okay
site let's don't write this yet but sine
of negative theta equals negative sine
theta that's true but I feel like this
amounts to saying that it's still it's
what I'm gonna do is not why like why
should that be the case I kind of have
it written on the board
mmm cosines what kind of function again
it's even what kind of function is so-so
is it odd function the definition the
definition of an odd function is that
this is the case right
that's our sine is an odd function
that's why excuse this an odd function
so I X to the 5 in fact any any X to the
odd number is going to be an odd
function
because that's why we call them odd
functions so that's why I can replace
this right that's why this is going to
become I actually would like to put the
negative there so I'm going to say minus
negative this since I'm running out of
space but you get the idea
sine theta is an odd function okay
and that that's w1 oops I lost an eye
somewhere there it is okay
did you see what I did do you see yeah
well four lines that I really need fault
lines enter if you want to show that
it's true then yes you need four lines
okay this is a little bit distinct to
suppose you you got this result and you
just wanted to work with it in order to
do something else solve some other kind
of problem okay if it wasn't the show
question then I wouldn't make such a big
deal about you give me the reasons you
could let me go there like one line
maybe okay because that's not the point
the question but this is the point of
the question sure okay I kind of heard
your hand through doing this part of it
doing this part can you have a go at
this one how would you state it what
reasons would you give I'll give you um
a couple minutes again ahead start early